boneless skinless chicken breasts can
get a bad rep for being boring and it's
one of the most common lean proteins out
there a ton of people buy it use it but
a lot of people don't know how to make
it really well with the right techniques
you can ensure a juicy flavorful chicken
breast
[Music]
one of the best ways to make your
chicken breasts more flavorful and
juicier is marinating it marinades in
part more flavor they seal in moisture
and they tenderize the meat so the first
thing i'm going to do is cube the
chicken this is totally optional you can
still use marinades with a full breast
but for this recipe i'm going to cube it
for our marinade i'm going to use soy
sauce lime juice brown sugar garlic
ginger and fresno chilies you can play
around with marinades and use tons of
different options it's really up to
personal preference and what flavors you
like you actually want to avoid using
oil and marinades meat is about 80 water
and oil doesn't actually penetrate the
flesh whereas something like salt will
you could use herbs or lemon garlic and
red pepper flakes you can really
customize it to what you want it to be
the important thing is to remember to
let it marinate for at least 30 minutes
so that it fully penetrates the skin so
for this recipe i'm going to put the
cubed meat onto skewers before baking it
if you're using wooden skewers make sure
to soak them in water for at least 10
minutes if not longer to prevent the
skewers from burning and drying out the
chicken bake it at 425 degrees for 15 to
20 minutes that's it you're done it's
that easy marinating chicken is a great
way to impart flavor but it does take
nearly an hour here's a faster way to
get really flavorful chicken breast a
spice rub is a great alternative to a
marinade because it's really fast and
simple to make we're using salt pepper
garlic powder paprika chili powder and
cumin you can absolutely play around
just make sure salt is one of the
ingredients in your spice rub pepper two
a spice rub may feel like a lot in
comparison to just adding salt and
pepper and it absolutely does add more
flavor you really want to be generous
with the amount of spices that you're
using once you've made your spice rub
make sure to evenly coat each chicken
breast and that's it it's super simple
super fast now we can move on to the
next step preheat the pan over medium
heat and then coat the bottom with oil
once the oil begins to shimmer you can
add the chicken breast without moving
let it cook for six to ten minutes on
each side depending on how thick the
chicken breast is you don't want to move
the chicken around a lot you're only
going to flip it once once the internal
temperature is at 165 you're ready to
take it off the pan after you're done
cooking let the chicken rest for about
five minutes just so it can fully absorb
all the juices that's it it's super
quick super simple and it results in
really flavorful chicken breasts
boneless skinless chicken breasts are a
great option for people that are more
health conscious but oftentimes it's
just what people gravitate towards but
if you really want to expand your
culinary horizons you should look
towards other cuts of chicken
bone in skin on chicken thighs are even
more foolproof they inherently have much
more flavor and they're actually really
easy to make
if you want to up your chicken game
check out this technique
in terms of seasoning salt and pepper
will go a long way it's already super
flavorful on its own we're also going to
add a little thyme and rosemary just to
give it an extra kick we're going to
heat the pan over medium-high heat and
add oil until it starts to glisten add
the chicken thighs skin side down and
you're going to cook it for a few
minutes until it becomes golden brown
and crispy with any protein with skin
you always want to start skin side down
and cook it for the majority of the time
like that it should take four to six
minutes for the skin to crisp up once it
does flip it over and cook it for about
two to three minutes or until the bottom
becomes golden brown at this point you
can put it straight in the oven and be
done with the dish but we're gonna add a
little extra flavor so remove the
chicken thighs from the pan and then add
onions and cook until they're softened
add a few lemon slices on top of the
onions put the chicken back on and then
pop it in the oven at 375 for 15 to 20
minutes it truly couldn't be easier
there's so many ways you can make
boneless skinless chicken breasts more
interesting but we really encourage you
to get out there and try other cuts of
chicken try these new techniques and see
what'll happen
expand your poultry horizons
i don't know poultry is not a great word
culture is not a great word
[Music]